[MUSIC PLAYING]
ARUN VENKATARAMAN: Perfect.
Good afternoon.
Thank you all for being here.
My name is Arun Venkataraman.
I am a member of the
News Lab at Google.
It's our pleasure to have at
Talks at Google here with us
today, James Crabtree.
Mr. Crabtree is the former
bureau chief of the "Financial
Times" in Mumbai, currently a
professor at the Lee Kuan Yew
School of Public
Policy at the National
University of Singapore.
And he's written
this fantastic book,
"The Billionaire Raj, a Journey
Through India's Gilded Age."
The book has received
fantastic reviews
from "Publisher Weekly."
"Washington Post" called it
one of the seven business
books that won't put you to
sleep at the beach this summer.
And having read it on vacation
the last couple of weeks,
I can certainly attest to that.
It's a fantastic
book, a fantastic look
at India in this
moment, as you call it,
of where it faces its
kind of national remaking.
I think we'll jump
straight into it.
And I kind of want
to start off with you
do this really great job
of setting up the broader
evolution of the Indian
political economy,
from the British
Raj before 1947,
the License Raj between '47
and liberalization in '91,
and leading to the
current moment, which
is the rise of the
billionaire Raj.
Would love for you
to kind of talk
through kind of the evolution
of that Indian political economy
and why we should think
about the billionaire Raj
as the defining characteristic
of the current Indian economic
moment.
JAMES CRABTREE:
OK, so thank you.
Thank you very
much for having me.
I moved to India in 2011
as a foreign correspondent
for the "Financial Times."
And so I landed in Mumbai,
the financial capital,
one morning in
November of that year.
And I was picked up by a driver,
as often happens in India.
And so we wound our
way through Mumbai,
through the sort of past the
slums outside of the airport
fence, down through the city,
which for those of you who
don't know it, is a very
fast and exciting city, much
like New York, the
financial capital.
And as we came
down into midtown,
the driver sort of
slowed the car down
and started pointing excitedly
out of the window up ahead.
And what he was pointing
to was this building
on the front cover of the book,
which is called Antilia, which
is the home of Mukesh Ambani,
who is India's richest
man and now Asia's richest man
as well, with a fortune of $44
billion at last count.
And so this house is a family
home for Mr. Ambani, his wife,
and their three children.
It's 170 meters tall.
It has 2/3 of the floor space
of the Palace of Versailles,
even though it's set on a plot
of not much more than an acre.
It has an extraordinary
range of interior features--
hanging gardens,
an ice room, which
is like a sauna in reverse,
where apparently you
can escape from
the heat of Mumbai,
has six floors of parking.
It has a sub-basement in which
they have an indoor football
pitch and a basketball court.
And beyond all of those
things, it sort of
has stood for the excess of
what I call the billionaire Raj.
Because even in a world of
galloping inequality here
in California, this is a
problem that people talk about.
It's true in China.
But nowhere else in the world
is there a house of this kind.
This is known as the Billion
Dollar Home in India's press.
And it's particularly
sort of galling,
I suppose, in a
city like Mumbai,
where half of the
population live in slums.
And so that in a sense, it
has become the icon of what
I call the billionaire Raj.
And there are three fault
lines in India's society
that I identify as being
associated with this,
one of which is the rise of
a new class of super wealthy
that have risen up, partly
since 1991, as you suggest,
but actually really in
the last 10 or 15 years.
And so the sort of story
of India's recent history
is one of re-globalization.
Up until 1991, for the 40
years since independence,
India closed itself
off from the world
and developed a not
terribly successful
socialist planned economy.
It tore that down in 1991.
But it was really only in
the middle of the 2000s,
around the time of the long
economic boom in this country
and China's rise,
that India fully
reintegrated with
the global economy.
And that meant you
had a large number
of people who became very
rich for reasons that we
can get into.
But in the middle
of the 1990s, India
had only two billionaires.
Now it has something like 120.
It has created wealth at
the very pinnacle of society
more quickly than almost any
other country in history.
You can compare what's happened
with Russia in the early 1990s.
And so while India has a pretty
good record of lifting people
out of poverty, and hundreds
of millions of Indians
have been lifted out of poverty
over the last 10 or 15 years,
nonetheless, it's
created an economic model
where most of the
proceeds of growth
have gone shooting up
to the very, very top.
And this remains a
quite poor country.
Average income in India
is still only $1,700.
To enter the 1%, you only need
an income of about $38,000,
so not very much.
So what we're
talking about here is
the real top, top, top,
top, top of the tree.
But for those people like
Mr. Ambani and the 0.0001%,
they have wealth that is
comparable to the very
richest in the world
and in a country that
remains rather unequal.
Along with that have been two
other problems that we could
get into, one of which is the
rise of crony capitalism, which
again is wound up in
India's re-globalization,
that as the economy
became more valuable,
then what had previously been
an endemic but small-bore form
of corruption developed into a
really big form of corruption
in the middle of
the last decade.
And that has been
a big battle in
the Indian political and
business system about how
you deal with crony capitalism
that is still being fought.
And then there's a
third fault line,
which relates to the way India's
industrial economy works.
There was a huge boom
around the same time
that this building
was being built
before the global
financial crisis.
That boom ended in a
bit of a jarring crunch.
And India has since
been trying to recover
from the problems
that were caused then,
which are excessive debt taken
on by its new tycoon class
and over-leverage in
the banking system.
And so these three fault lines
are what I discuss in the book
and what I say are the sort of
challenges of the billionaire
Raj.
This is an optimistic
book, at least in theory.
Because I see no
particular reason
why India can't overcome
these challenges.
But I suppose the
argument in the book
is that it's not going
to happen by accident.
ARUN VENKATARAMAN: And
you talk about, in fact,
in the book I think, there's
a $150 billion in bad assets
that the banks currently
own from this tycoon class.
Getting to the dual reasons
of this boom and bust cycle
and then the crony capitalism
that you kind of position
as being the primary reasons for
fueling the rise of this tycoon
class or the billionaire Raj
over the last 10, 12 years.
Why is that fundamentally
problematic for India's
development writ large?
Why is it an issue that you
have crony capitalism as rampant
as it is, a boom and bust cycle?
And how does that hinder India's
ability to grow going forward?
JAMES CRABTREE: Well, if
you compare India to China--
so China has executed a sort of
once-in-a-lifetime trick over
the last 30 years, which is it
has grown pretty much unbroken
over 7% for about two decades.
And that's unprecedented
in economic history.
Almost no country
has ever done that.
And nonetheless, India is
trying to do something similar.
The quicker you grow at a high
rate uninterrupted, the more
quickly you move out of poverty
and become a middle income
country.
As I say, what China has
managed to do is very unusual.
Typically what happens is you
can grow fast for a while.
And then you sort of,
you get found out.
And you fall over.
And so in a sense, the problem
with India's boom and bust
cycle is it impinges
on its development.
But it raises a sort of
more interesting question.
So there's been a big change in
the way India's economy works.
The simplest way
I can explain it
is that before the
reforms in 1991,
and to some degree for
the 10 years after that,
you had a situation where
capital was expensive,
but politics was easy.
So it was hard to raise money.
You couldn't get financing.
There were no
international banks
so you had to rely on a
kind moldy state banking
system, which was
locked up in all sorts
of ridiculous restrictions.
But if you were a
businessman, you
learned how to work the
system, the good ones.
Some people call
it crony socialism.
Your friends in
politics helps you out.
You bend the rules a little bit.
The people who
prospered were the ones
who knew how to work
the political system.
And what happened
after the mid 2000,
and particularly after you had
a range of corruption scandals,
was that flipped on its head.
So capital became much cheaper,
much easier to raise money.
And so the tycoons raised
huge amounts of money,
borrowed mostly from
state bank banks.
But then suddenly, politics
became very difficult.
Because in the aftermath
of the corruption
scandals of the mid 2000s,
India is a democracy.
It has a free press.
It has an independent judiciary,
which is at its upper levels,
at least broadly
impartial and not corrupt.
It has a vibrant civil society.
And all of these groups--
and it has a growing, if
still small, middle class.
All four of those groups became
very attuned to corruption.
And so it became much more
difficult for the tycoons
to work the political system
as they did in the past.
And that was
especially true after
the current prime
minister, Narendra Modi,
was elected in
2014 in a landslide
election in which he stood on
an anti-corruption platform.
And so this new environment
that India finds itself in,
in which capital is
much easier to get
than it was before,
or at least has been,
but the political system is much
more difficult. What it means
is the old system
that India was using
to build steel mills and mines
and toll roads is now broken.
But there isn't a new system.
And that's a big
problem if you're
a country in the early
stages of industrialization.
Because while
people look at India
and they see its tech
economy, for instance,
the cities like Bangalore
and Hyderabad, which
have vibrant startups and
big outsourcing companies,
but in the end, you can't
develop with just that.
You need to have the basic
infrastructural development
in roads and sewerage
and ports and railways
that every other
developing country that
has moved from poverty to
middle income status and onwards
towards rich economy
status has managed.
And so if India's
industrial engine
is broken or problematic,
then that's a big issue.
ARUN VENKATARAMAN:
That brings up,
I think, a comparison that
you draw between the moment
that India is currently in
and let's say that the United
States was in during the
Gilded Age or England
was in in the time of Dickens,
where you kind of have
this very interesting dynamic.
Because with two, three,
sorry, primary stakeholders,
the state institution
or state apparatus
fails to provide basic needs and
basic services infrastructure
to its people.
Opportunistic politicians
kind of seize that kind of gap
by providing patronage or
providing those resources
in exchange for votes.
And then those
kind of politicians
are being supported
with resources
from the moneyed class
and kind of fueling
this situation in
which politicians
in the moneyed class
might continue to do well.
But the basic needs of
people go on being unmet.
And it kind of speaks to some
of the ways in which I think
crony capitalism has manifested
to make it difficult for India
to develop in the ways that I
think we'd all hope it would.
What does it take to
break through that?
What do you need to break this
toxic web of interdependency
between these three stakeholders
in Indian political society?
JAMES CRABTREE: I mean,
that's a great question.
So Francis Fukuyama,
the social theorist
and political scientist, writes
a lot on corruption and trust
and says that actually, the
move from a society based
on patronage to one that is
based on neutral rules applied
evenly between groups is much
more complicated than moving
from poverty to
middle income status,
that this is an incredibly
difficult development
challenge.
I mean, one of the reasons why
I say this is an optimistic book
is that, in a sense, if you
were sitting not necessarily
here in San Francisco, but if
you were sitting in Manhattan
in 1880 and you had looked at
the situation of the United
States at that time, you would
have been pretty depressed.
This was a moment in which
America had a venal billionaire
class that had taken much of the
wealth that had been generated
after the Civil War and
had pocketed it for itself
and used that to build
beautiful mansions in New York
and on the cliff tops of
Newport, Rhode Island.
And they were
working hand-in-glove
with machine politics at
the city or local level that
was rapacious and not
interested in ordinary people.
And you might have
been fairly depressed
about America's prospects.
But within 10 or
20, 30 years, you
have the move that is commonly
called the move from the Gilded
Age to the Progressive
Era, which is
a complicated set of changes.
But the middle class began to
assert control over politics.
You had the
development of a kind
of free press that went on to
become one of the world's most
admirable, a range
of other developments
that gradually meant that a
political movement that busted
up some of the
monopolies that were
held by the moneyed
class at the top.
And so you had a range
of different changes
that changed America
very fundamentally
in this early stage
of industrialization.
I see no particular reason why
that can't happen in India.
The sort of nexus
that you're talking,
about, however, it is
difficult to break.
You need to build up
state services that
are of reasonable quality
so that people don't have
to rely on things that are
provided through patronage
networks.
You have to drain the swamp
of the political funding
system, which is--
we can talk about this
more if you like--
sort of the original sin
of the Indian system,
that it has a very expensive
political system, which
is almost entirely
funded under the table
with illegal donations.
And you have to create a
much more competitive market
economy, so one that is a sort
of rules-based economy rather
than a--
pro-market rather
than pro-business
is one of the ways
people describe it,
so not one where the political
class is doing favors
for particular businesses but
by which everyone has to play
by the same competitive rules.
But those things are not easy.
It's sort of easier
said than done.
ARUN VENKATARAMAN: It definitely
gets to the idea, I think.
And it's a quote that you
mentioned in the book,
that more than the
type of government,
the degree of government is
what's most important, I think.
It's initially
from Fukuyama also.
I guess in terms of
things that could
be done to supercharge
or accelerate
the degree of government--
we are at Google,
so I feel compelled
to ask, what role do you feel
technology companies could
play or should play?
Should they have a role in
supercharging or accelerating
the efforts of building
out a more robust state
apparatus that can meet
the needs of its people?
JAMES CRABTREE: I
think there's two ways
of answering that
question, both of which
are reasons for optimism.
So the first thing is this
book focuses mostly on what
you might call bad guys.
But India is not Russia.
The reason why I'm much
more optimistic about India
in the medium to long
term is that there
are large parts of the
Indian economy that
are, broadly speaking,
sort of market
competitive and innovative.
And the tech sector, both its
heritage outsourcing but also
its newer startup
culture, are part of that.
And they have produced
a lot of rich people.
And there's absolutely
no problem with that.
The same is true with
generic pharmaceuticals
manufacturing, or bits of
the automotive supply chain,
or there's a whole bunch
of bits of finance.
The private sector finance
economy banks are high quality,
competitive institutions.
And to the extent
that these guys have
made an absolute fortune, as
long as they pay their taxes
and are sort of reasonably
socially responsible,
I don't think any of us should
have any problem with that.
And so one way in which the tech
economy can kind of play a role
here is by simply
continuing to grow
and crowding out the rest of
the people in a different part
of the economy.
That, however, is
not a perfect answer.
Because you can't simply create
a prosperous middle income
economy only by looking
at the tech sector.
You know, you need growth
that is broadly-based.
And ideally, you want
all of your sectors,
including extractive industries
and property, the traditionally
very corrupt sectors,
you want them also
to have high
governance standards.
And so well, what
can technology do?
Partly one of the ways in which
the government of Narendra
Modi, the prime
minister, has begun
to tackle some of the
corruption in India
is by moving official
processes online.
So literally in India, if you
need to go and get a vehicle
license, you have to go
to some moldy old office
in some distant
part of the city.
And unless you are
very lucky, someone's
going to ask you for a bribe.
There's sort of
the any individuals
have lots of discretion.
And that's true
with all sorts of--
they call them permissions
in India, the sort of box
tick you need to get if
you need to do something.
And so if you're trying
to run a business,
you often need thousands,
tens of thousands,
sometimes millions, of
these things if you're
a very large enterprise, to do
with property, the environment,
air quality,
whatever it might be.
The more of these
you can move online
and the more you
take discretion away
from individuals who can
then use it as an opportunity
to sort of extract
money, and make
this a kind of mutual
rules-based system.
And there's a lot
of power in that.
And so India has already--
and other countries
in Asia as well--
have already shown that that's
a quite effective corruption
reduction strategy.
And so that, I think,
is one way in which
technology can play a big part.
ARUN VENKATARAMAN: What
is your sense of some
of the more ambitious or
kind of grander schemes,
like Aadhaar, for
example, that are kind of
trying to use
digitization or next-level
technology to make state
functions a little bit more
efficient?
JAMES CRABTREE:
Yeah, so Aadhaar,
which is a biometric
identification system that
was the idea and
was pushed by a guy
called Nandan Nilekani,
who's the founder of Infosys,
one of the heritage
outsourcing companies--
and in a sense, he
is an absolute emblem
of what you might call the
good billionaires as opposed
to the bad.
I mean, he personally is as
honest as the day is long.
He has a deep commitment
to public service.
And the Aadhaar, which
he helped to set up,
has become a great
success story.
It's the sort of one of
the layers in what they
call the India stack, which
is a range of technology
applications which
makes it much easier
to connect individual users,
particularly those who are very
poor, into the banking
and financial system
and then onwards
into products that
require that, like
mobile payments
and that sort of thing.
And actually, I mean,
it's been very successful.
It's now used by more
than a billion people.
So it's very
difficult now in India
to do anything without
an Aadhaar card.
And so if you're
a startup and you
want to do something
which requires
quick and easy
identification, verification,
and then access into
banking and other sorts
of financial products,
it's vastly easier
than it was even two
or three years ago.
You know, this system
has its critics.
There are some people who
worry not so much about Aadhaar
itself, but about the
security and data protection
of the wider ecosystem of
companies that are now building
things off the back of it.
But typically, I think
that's a good example
of what the Indian
state can achieve
if it puts its mind to it.
The problem is that that is
a rather isolated example
of success.
And there are whole
swathes of other areas
that are pretty much as
hopeless as they used to be.
So in a sense, you need
to take that rather
inspirational example
and then move it around
much more broadly.
ARUN VENKATARAMAN: And
apply it at scale--
it strikes me that--
I mean, I think the grand
conclusion or recommendation
from the book is
doing what it takes
to usher in this
progressive era that
might be able to move
India from the Gilded Age
to higher levels of development.
It strikes me that one of the
components of that you need
is a kind of a fierce,
independent kind
of muckraking media class
or journalism class.
And I'm putting on my News
Lab hat a little bit here.
You have this really
fascinating chapter
in the book about of the rise
of Arnab Goswami over the course
of the last 10 years.
And I think it's kind
of a nuanced chapter
where you suggest, is
this newly activist media
class emblematic of
yellow journalism in the--
not just the Pulitzer but
the world model in the 1890s?
Or is it like
muckraking journalism,
like Upton Sinclair's
"The Jungle."
I mean, what's your sense of
how it's treading that line?
And as you see journalism
move increasingly to digital,
is it more susceptible to
being yellow journalism
than the muckraking
variety it needs?
JAMES CRABTREE: Yeah, so
it's another great question.
And I could talk
about this for hours.
Because obviously,
I'm a journalist.
And so I love this question.
I mean, my starting position
with the Indian media
is I live in Singapore.
And I would much rather
have the Indian media
than the Singaporean or many
other of the East Asian medias.
I admire the fearless, messy,
often wholly inaccurate
but spirited South
Asian press more
than the much more restrained,
deferential East Asian press.
I think if you come from
an Anglo-Saxon background,
you take the Indian media over
an East Asian media any day
of the week.
That, however, is not to
say that there are not
very substantial issues.
And I think there has been a
degradation in the Indian media
ecosystem that is
partly to do with what
you might call the Fox
Newsification of broadcast
news.
So in the book, I
focus on a gentleman
called Arnab Goswami, who's
kind of the Sean Hannity or Bill
O'Reilly of India.
He's a very outspoken
evening talk show host.
He's quite right wing,
although he initially
found his feet as an
anti-corruption campaigner.
And he claims, I think
with some justification,
that he is sort of
personally liberal
and sort of speaks out on things
like women's and gay rights.
But increasingly,
he is associated
with something that would be
quite similar to a sort of Fox
News agenda, a right
wing nationalism that
is very supportive
of Narendra Modi
and spends its time beating up
on Pakistan on the evening news
and that sort of thing.
That's one problem.
You then have a problem
of social media.
I should watch my words
carefully in this audience.
But increasingly, I view
social media in India
as a complete cesspit.
I mean, Twitter in particular,
it's a very tough environment
and one where established
norms of behavior
that you would have
in other forms of life
increasingly don't exist.
And I am increasingly troubled
by that, as are many people.
And it's unclear to me
quite what you do about it.
But the social media genie
has many positive sides.
But there's clearly
a lot of negatives
in terms of what it does to
public discourse in a country
that has deep preexisting
social divisions of particularly
religion, but also caste and
all sorts of other things.
And India, with the
best will in the world,
does not have the strongest
existing media institutions.
So it does have a reasonable
suite of broadcast newspapers,
broadsheet newspapers.
But it doesn't have a kind
of "New York Times" or a BBC
or a "Le Monde" or
something like that.
And then you have
a problem, which
will be core to what you're
looking at in News Lab, which
is a business model problem,
which is at the moment.
I think it's a
trick of the light
that the Indian press appears
to be doing quite well.
You have a huge population
it's growing and learning
to read for the first time.
Illiteracy rates are falling.
People are becoming wealthy.
And so the newspapers,
on the surface,
look like their business
models are reasonably robust.
But I'm 100% convinced that
that is a trick of the light.
And exactly the
same tsunami that
has washed over the media
industry in the West
is going to wash
over the Indian media
industry with almost twice
the force, because it's going
to happen much more quickly.
The shift from people
not having smartphones
to having smartphones and using
them for absolutely everything
is happening with
enormous speed,
much more quickly than it
did in the UK and the US.
And so I think a lot of these
heritage media institutions
are just going to get
completely swamped
unless they adapt
even more nimbly
than the best of the global
institutions have managed.
So I think the Indian ecosystem
is an interesting one.
But it raises a bigger question
and a much bigger picture
issue about why we should
all care about India.
In this audience, you're
part of the Indian diaspora.
Many of you have
connections to India.
But in a sense, look
up from 50,000 feet.
China is clearly heading
in the wrong direction.
China is sliding
backwards into a form
of neo-Leninist autocracy.
The notion that China is
going to become even a country
like Singapore in the
next 10 or 20 years
now seems to be almost
beyond possibility.
Russia, Turkey, many of the
most important developing
economies in the world are
slipping backwards into forms
of--
even the United States
to some degree--
into forms of nationalism
that those of us
who believe in a kind of
liberal, multicultural
worldview find
rather regrettable.
India remains the
swing superpower.
It is at the earliest
stage of its development
of any of these countries.
Its story is the one that
is yet to be written.
And it remains a
parliamentary democracy
with a constitution
that enshrines
liberal rights of
the sort that would
be very familiar to people in
the United Kingdom or United
States.
It's a multi-faith democracy.
And it's perfectly possible that
by the middle of this century,
India will be a sort
of upper middle income
parliamentary democracy in
which various faiths in a very
complicated society live broadly
in harmony with one another
in a market economy.
And that would be not just
a good thing for India
in my view, but a good
thing for the whole world,
particularly our bit of it.
And so in that sense, one of
the underlying arguments in this
book-- and it links to the point
about having a democratic free
press as opposed to China
in particular and some other
countries in Asia--
we all have a huge
stake in the success
of the current Indian model and
should be watching developments
there very closely.
ARUN VENKATARAMAN: It
strikes me, I think--
and it's a question that you
position at the very beginning
of the book--
India is in a moment
of national remaking.
And it can kind of double
down on the liberal democratic
values that you just
highlighted are its strengths.
It seems to me that you also
hear, as a part of the broader
conversation, that India
maybe should course
correct and take on a more
right wing, autocratic--
kind of go the way of China, or
to a lesser extent, Singapore.
And that might grease
some of the inefficiencies
of the Indian state.
Kind of taking a step back,
it can go the progressive era
mode.
Or it can take a more
kind of like strongman,
autocratic leadership that
builds a very efficient state
apparatus sort of direction.
Do you sense that
that is the right way
to frame the two directions
that it could potentially
go moving forward to address
some of these broader issues?
JAMES CRABTREE: I mean,
I understand the impulse
behind that
suggestion, which comes
from a place of frustration,
which is that as recently
as 1990, 1995, India
and China were basically
in the same place from
a kind of economic size,
GDP per capita sense.
And then China raced
away and is now
a vastly richer country than
India and much more successful.
And so I can
understand the impulse
to say, well, if our political
system was a little bit more
like theirs, then if we
weren't a messy democracy
and that meant that we didn't
have to put up with people,
we could just bulldoze
them out of the way
like the Chinese did, then
we could build more roads.
We'd get more done.
And that would make it easier.
And so I understand
that impulse.
I'm not sure it is the
best example to go for.
Many European and
American countries
have managed to build
good infrastructure
without requiring
a dictatorship.
Equally, China is a much
more homogeneous society
than India is-- not
a very good model.
The Han Chinese make up
the vast majority of China.
India is a stunningly diverse
society in all of its ways.
It seemed much more like Europe
than the heritage United States
or China.
And the risks of, in a sense,
a more majoritarian politics,
which in a country that is
80% Hindu inevitably means
a majoritarian
Hindu politics, it
comes with a number of risks.
I mean, in the end, social
divisions are not always
good for economic growth,
not simply because--
but the risk is you have
periods of social unrest.
So anyway, I think India
would be better advised
to stick with a
system that protects
the rights of its
minorities and simply
tries to work on making
its state work better.
There's nothing really wound
up in the world of democracy
per se, which is limiting India
from improving what people
tend to call state capacity.
And state capacity,
underneath all of this,
is really the answer
to India's problems.
It has a weak state.
It's poorly resourced.
It doesn't have
enough smart people.
It is corrupt.
And there's nothing
inherently about democracy
which stops you from building
high-quality state capacity.
It was done in many
other countries.
And so I think this
notion that India can only
succeed if it sort
of gradually cleaves
towards a form of
authoritarianism is risky.
ARUN VENKATARAMAN: You
mentioned in the book
that part of the difficulty
with implementing grand change,
despite even, for example,
the ambitions of the Modi
government over the course
of the last five years,
is the inherent kind
of fractious nature
of India's political
and cultural landscape.
The changes that you propose
in the book or the changes
that you propose
India needs to make
are huge, not insignificant by
any stretch of the imagination.
And yet you remain
optimistic that India
can go in that direction.
Given how divided and fractious
this political cultural
environment is,
what gives you, I
guess, faith that India is going
to retain its democratic roots
and still find a way
to strengthen its state
capacity to ameliorate
some of the broader issues
that it faces?
JAMES CRABTREE: Well, I think my
optimism about India, as I say,
is based on historical precedent
from other countries that
have managed to do this.
It's also based on the
stronger and more innovative
parts of India's economy.
I see examples of where
the Indian state is
very successful.
So you mentioned Aadhaar.
People point to its
electoral system.
So Indian elections
are a great miracle.
They're, broadly-speaking--
all sorts of problems with
the Indian democratic system--
but the elections
themselves, these mass
festivals of democracy that
happen every four or five
years, they're always
the largest election
in human history.
They're run fairly efficiently
on a shoestring budget.
People point to the Indian Space
program, which has sent rockets
into space at almost no cost.
So there are plenty of examples
of when the Indian state puts
its mind to it, that it can
achieve extraordinary things
at low cost.
And the talent of
the Indian people
is a remarkable thing to behold.
You only have to look at
the strength of the diaspora
population here in
the United States.
Hinduism is America's
richest religion.
We're here in Silicon Valley,
where the Indian diaspora is
overwhelmingly the most
successful of immigrant groups.
If you look at
immigrant-founded businesses,
technology businesses,
then it isn't even close.
Indians found more successful
technology businesses
here than all of the rest of the
immigrant groups put together,
including the Chinese
and the Taiwanese,
who are the second
and third most
sort of impressive groupings.
And so I see no particular
reason why this can't happen.
But as I say, it's not
going to happen by accident.
And I don't want to
underestimate the challenge.
I suppose what I would
say is that someone who
lived in India for five
years, my son was born there--
my son, as we were
talking about earlier,
has an Indian middle name--
and as with many
people who visit India,
I emerged in a sense
very fond of the country.
I think that's not
always true of people
who go to live in China, foreign
correspondents who live there.
They find it a more challenging
and frustrating experience
because of the nature
of the political system.
Again, that is not to downplay
some of the rougher edges
of Indian society.
But I think you come
out sort of admiring
the strengths of the
Indian political system
and wishing it well.
And in a sense,
as an outsider who
decided that I wanted to write
a book about India because I
thought I had some experiences
there that were worth
sharing, that's the
perspective that I come from,
sort of a friend who's tried
to make a few contributions
to a much broader debate
about how India moves out
of poverty and through
middle income status
and towards being
a rich economy,
as many other countries
have done before.
ARUN VENKATARAMAN: No, I
mean, it's interesting.
Even though you were
exposed certainly,
I'm sure, to the darker
underbelly of Indian society,
that you've still sort of
emerged out of the process
feeling optimistic
about its future,
which I think is nice
for those of us who
are part of the Indian
diaspora, and just
like humanity writ
large and recognize
the stakes of bringing
hundreds of millions of people,
if not a 1.7 billion people's
potential to fruition.
I want to open it
up to questions now.
Oh, sorry, there's a mic
in the back you guys can--
AUDIENCE: Do you want
me to walk over there?
JAMES CRABTREE:
Yeah, I believe so.
AUDIENCE: So it's
interesting that you
called India kind of
like a swing country
when you compare it to
countries like Turkey and China,
which are more falling towards
more authoritarian regimes.
Because it seems
like Narendra Modi
was elected with a landslide.
But he is stoking a little
bit of a nationalistic India,
like Hindus versus Muslim
kind of tension in order
to forward the BJP's
control over the country
or the political system.
So could you talk more
about your thoughts
on Narendra Modi, what you
think he signifies for India,
and if there are pros and
cons about what he's done
and what he represents?
JAMES CRABTREE: Yeah.
So it's a great question.
Narendra Modi is the dominant
figure of the age in India.
And although I set
out to write a book
about the rise of
the super rich,
I very quickly discovered
that it's basically impossible
to grapple with the
state of modern India
unless you have an account
of Modi, who he is,
and what he stands for.
He's a remarkable figure
in a number of ways.
For those of you who are
less familiar with him,
he was born in poverty.
He's from the lower castes.
He's famously a
self-described son
of a tea seller, a chaiwala.
And so in the book,
I go and visit
the village that he grew up
in in the state of Gujarat.
He's immensely controversial
because he presided over
an episode of ethnic violence
in the early 2000s in which
many thousands of Muslims died.
And his critics say
that if he did not
exacerbate this
violence that he didn't
do nearly enough to stop it.
So he was banned for the
best part of a decade
from traveling to
the United States.
He wasn't welcome in
most Western countries.
And then he's a contradictory
figure, as you say.
So on the one hand,
he won election
on an anti-corruption
platform and is
seen to be a pro-growth,
pro-market, pro-jobs sort
of leader.
He's a technocrat.
He believes in building big
infrastructure projects.
He's obsessed with bullet
trains and solar parks.
And he loves technology.
He has nearly as many Twitter
followers as Donald Trump.
When Donald Trump met him, he
rather graciously pointed out
that Narendra Modi had
the second largest number
of Twitter followers
of anyone in the world.
And yet as you say, he
is a Hindu nationalist.
In his younger days,
he was, in a sense,
a sort of proselytizing
religious figure
for a right wing,
Hindu nationalist,
civil society group
called the RSS.
And he would--
this was in the era
before India's
economy opened up--
and so he would walk or take
a scooter from town to town.
This was in an era really before
any Indians had televisions.
And so he would
preach the good news.
He would go and have
meetings with people,
sit around kitchen
tables, and tell them
about what the Hindu
nationalists thought was
going on in the world.
And so he stands
against the tradition
that I talked about earlier,
the values of secularism that
are enshrined in
India's constitution.
And so that's when I say that
India is a swing superpower.
I suppose I mean
that this is in play.
It doesn't seem to me that India
is sliding inevitably backwards
into a form of populist
nationalism along the lines
that Turkey or certainly
Russia has followed.
China is a different case
but equally depressing.
Nonetheless, I think
fair-minded people
could agree that the
secular tradition in India
is in a pretty weakened
position at the moment.
The Congress Party that
was the standard bearer
of that tradition for
most of India's existence
has been reduced to
a parliamentary rump
of less than 50 seats.
Its leadership is not popular.
And so it's sort
of unclear where
the future of that strand
of India's politics
is made up from.
And then there are all
sorts of other forms
of nationalist
identity-- caste-based
politics, religious
politics in India.
It's a very complicated
and combustible society.
Nonetheless, I don't think
that there is as much reason
for pessimism as
there are in some
of these other
autocratic countries.
And so when I say that it's a
swing superpower, what I mean
is that it could go, to some
degree, one way or the other.
I don't think India
is going to become
a new version of Russia, a
kind of oligarchic kleptocracy.
I think there was a risk
of that 10 years ago.
I think that risk has
thankfully receded somewhat.
But there is a future in
which India would remain,
and it's already probably
the most unequal country
in the world, right up there
with South Africa and Brazil.
But it's reached that point
at a much earlier stage
in its economic development.
And so the risk is if
it continues to grow
and the proceeds of that
growth are taken overwhelmingly
by people at the top, you
have a potential future
in which India becomes
unprecedentedly
unequal for a large economy.
And you can also get a situation
in which Indian politics
becomes much more combustible.
This is a country that has
nearly 300 million Muslims.
And so if that
substantial minority
begins to feel that
they have no protection
within the political system,
then that is a big problem.
And it's not just that
particular minority.
There are lots of other
minority groups as well.
And so that, in a sense,
is why many, I think,
outsiders to India look at
the values that were enshrined
in the constitution
and say, well, look,
this is a pretty
good place to start.
It's not perfect.
But you don't want
to throw this away.
Because with a country
as diverse as India,
this is the sort
of thing that you
need to keep things
relatively stable.
ARUN VENKATARAMAN: Yeah.
I think one of the interesting
parts of the book, one
of the parts that
really jumped out to me,
was when you talk
about the ghettoization
of the Muslim
population in Ahmedabad
in the aftermath of the
Godhra riots in 2002.
And I think it
speaks to a kind of--
when you say it's
a swing state, it
could veer the
opposite direction.
But it's kind of a
crucible moment for India.
JAMES CRABTREE: I mean, that's
a really good example of what--
so if you go to--
Narendra Modi grew up in the
northwestern state of Gujarat.
And it's a sort of
interesting example
of a theoretical
question, which is,
do economic growth
and social harmony
necessarily go hand in hand?
In theory, people
in this room and me,
too, we like to think, let's
be nice to one another.
That will be good for growth.
We'll all get along.
And then the economy
will grow fine.
But actually, the
Indian lesson of that
is not necessarily the case.
So Gujarat has been one of
India's most successful states.
It's the closest that India
has to the Pearl River
Delta in China.
It is industrialized.
It's relatively corruption-free.
It attracts a lot of
foreign investment.
You have huge factories.
Ford have a huge
factory there, GE.
So it's sort of an
economic model for India.
And many people look
at that and say,
OK, well, if we could have that
economy across all of India,
India would be in
a great position.
You know, India is
already more like,
in many parts of the country,
so in that part of the country,
in Tamil Nadu where
your parents are from,
much more like a middle
income Southeast Asian country
than they are a sub-Saharan
African country.
In fact, the bits of India that
look like sub-Saharan Africa
are really shrinking.
And pretty soon, extreme
poverty of that sort
is going to be purely
an African phenomenon.
You're not going to see very
much of it even in South Asia.
But the problem is that Gujarat
has really terrible politics,
very caste-based
politics, but particularly
brutal for the Muslim minority.
And you see that in Ahmedabad,
where Muslims in Ahmedabad
live in a literal
ghetto, so not a ghetto
like you get in American
cities, which is somewhere
that only poor people live.
It's a ghetto like you
got in 19th century
European cities, where everybody
of that particular faith
lives-- so the Jews
in the Prague ghetto.
In Ahmedabad, every
Muslim in the city
pretty much lives in one area.
And they all moved there.
It was already a sort
of heritage Muslim area.
But people flocked together
for strength in numbers
after the events in
2002 because they just
didn't believe
that the state was
going to protect their rights.
And so from the poorest chaiwala
to the guy who owns the BMW
dealership, they all
live in this area,
which is a couple of
kilometers square.
And that's a real
indictment of Modi's record
as a chief minister
and those who
have come after him,
that minorities feel
so unsafe, both in the capacity
of the state, the police
and other forces, to protect
them in instances of violence
but also their suspicion of
the motivations of the ruling
majority.
And so that sort of thing
is potentially very damaging
in the medium term.
But it doesn't
necessarily stop you
building factories and
export-focused manufacturing.
So this is one of
the tensions I think
that India has to deal with.
ARUN VENKATARAMAN:
You, go ahead.
Looks like we have
another question.
AUDIENCE: Hey.
Thanks for coming here today.
So I actually moved
here five years ago.
And the questions that
you raise here right now,
I kind of asked myself this
while growing up back in India.
And what was clear to me was
that, while the state itself
promises a lot of benefits
to close the gap of income
inequality and have a lot
of benefits for the farmers,
for the poor, but
somewhere in the line
of a lot of bureaucrats,
these benefits get lost.
And they never even reach
farmers or poor people
who they were intended
for basically.
And so there's
this cycle, which I
think hasn't been broken
yet-- or I don't even
know if it can be broken--
of the state being corrupt,
like people not getting
economic mobility,
not having literacy, and
hence again backing up
politicians who exploit them
based on caste or religion.
And so the cycle
keeps on continuing.
So I don't see an end
in sight as to how
this cycle can be broken.
Do you have any
thoughts on this matter
as to how economic mobility
can actually happen and break
this chain of caste-based
and religion-based politics?
I think that's the only way
forward for India to move
in a scalable, progressive way.
But I don't see an end
in sight right now-- just
wanted your thoughts on that.
JAMES CRABTREE:
Well, so I think,
again, my bias is to try and
look for reasons for optimism.
And I think you can find them.
Where are you from in India?
AUDIENCE: New Delhi.
JAMES CRABTREE: Right.
So there we are.
So if you're from the north,
things always look bleaker.
But if you go to Southern India,
Southern India is by no means
perfect.
But it's much better
than the north
in terms of economic
development,
in terms of the way
the state works.
Southern India, Southern
and Western India
look much more like Thailand
than, I don't know, Congo.
The problems are very
North Indian issues.
So there are parts of
the country that perform
much better than others.
And so that suggests
that if you have
different institutional
arrangements,
things can improve.
I mean, there are just
things about the way
the Indian political
system works, which
are quite hard to grasp.
You will understand them, but it
took me a while as an outsider.
One thing which surprises
you as soon as you go there
is, in Britain or America,
the upper middle classes
vote in great numbers.
But the poor, those who
have less advantage,
often vote much less because
they see the system doesn't
deliver for them.
In India, it's precisely
the other way around.
Some of the lowest
voting figures
come from the richest
constituencies in the country,
in South Mumbai
and Central Delhi,
whereas if you're
a slum dweller,
you vote as a ritual act.
Absolutely everybody votes.
And that actually, in some
ways, entrenches the cycle
that you're talking about.
Because people attach themselves
to particular politicians.
Equally, tensions in
India, caste tensions,
religious tensions, do not
cause tensions in politics.
It's typically the
other way around.
It's the cycle of elections
which cause these tensions.
Politicians whip up
fervor amongst their base.
This is not unknown amongst
politicians in this country
to sort of manipulate
and whip up fervor
amongst their base for
political mobilization purposes.
That happens a lot in India.
I think in the end,
technocratic fixes
can begin to improve this.
So Arun, you mentioned
Aadhaar and what technology
can do to help.
I mean, in the end,
in the administration
of the beginnings of the
Indian social welfare state--
so giving money to people who
need it to feed their children
or subsidies for fuel to
cook or free school meals--
the administration
of these things
is often hopelessly corrupt.
But if you can move to
a system of, let's say,
direct cash transfers using a
combination of these identity
systems, mobile phones,
and bank accounts,
you could wipe out
almost at a stroke
all of the graft that
goes into those systems
and begin to create the
beginnings of a much more
supportive welfare state.
Now we're already
halfway down that road.
Now that won't make it
perfect, but it's an example
of what can be achieved.
But again, that's not to
underplay the distance
that India still has to go.
I mean, it's very hard to do
what a country like Singapore
did.
But even in Singapore,
it took 50 years.
And so in a sense,
you're talking
about kind of
generational-long effort
to introduce the systems
and the governance reforms,
to invest in public
administration,
to think about how
technology can help,
but not just technology.
Technology isn't going
to solve this on its own.
You need to pay public
officials good salaries
so that they don't
feel they need
to take things under the
table, all sort of things.
But other countries
have done this.
South Korea was
endemically corrupt.
So was Singapore when
Lee Kuan Yew took over.
Other countries have managed
gradually to break this cycle,
as America did before it.
So again, with
wise public policy,
it ought to be
possible to do it.
ARUN VENKATARAMAN: Do we have
time for one more question?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I think we
have time just for maybe
the two of us.
I have a quick
question from the Dory,
from Ramesh up in San Bruno.
Ramesh says, you had
mentioned, quote,
"radical options
have been ignored,
notably the privatization
of struggling public sector
lenders."
This is often discussed in
the media as the only option
to save public sector
lenders, which are
the backbone of rural India.
Why not other approaches?
JAMES CRABTREE: Well, so
what we're talking about here
is the nature of India's
financial system, which
is fairly state-dominated.
3/4 of assets in
the financial system
are held by state-backed banks.
A quarter are held by
private sector banks.
Broadly speaking, the private
sector banks are pretty good--
not all of them.
They have their flaws.
But some of them are very good.
And they're the darling
of Western investors.
Broadly speaking, the
state-backed banks
are pretty hopeless.
And so well, what
are your options?
You don't necessarily have
to privatize these things.
In fact, there are
theoretical risks
from doing mass
privatization programs.
And I wouldn't actually
recommend that per se.
But some of them
can be sold off.
Some of them can
simply be reformed.
You introduce better
management, different.
You make the
governance independent.
You can sell down the stake that
the state holds to below 50%.
So Singapore still has
substantial state holdings
of many of its formerly
state-run assets.
You have a sort of golden share.
But you don't need
to control and run
the whole thing by bureaucrats.
You can hand it
over to people who
actually know how to run banks.
So I don't think privatization
is the only answer.
I'm not a kind of
mad libertarian
who believes that you only
need to go down that route.
Nonetheless, India does have
a very unusual banking system
now.
Only really China
and maybe Vietnam
have a banking system that is
as state-dominated as India.
Across the rest of the emerging
world and the rich world,
typically you have
a different balance
between the state
and the market.
And the strategy that India is
following to reform its banking
system at the moment
is clearly the worst
of all worlds, which is
they've sort of given up
on the state-backed banks.
But they can't summon the
political will to reform them.
And they're just sort of
waiting for them to die.
And then the private
sector gradually,
by a sort of attritional
process, will win market share,
as it has been over
the last 10 years.
So it's sort of creeping up
from a fifth to a quarter
to a third.
That's a terrible way to
reform your banking system,
because it takes an
awfully long time.
And in the end, the wastage,
as opposed to the alternative
strategy, which is taking the
state-backed banks and either
aggressively reform them or
move some of them into private
ownership, something--
introduce new forms
of banking that
have a heavy technological
component as well--
India is about to go through
the same sort of payments
revolution that China
has been through--
then there's much quicker and
more optimistic set of reforms.
But at the moment, I have to say
the Indian government has not
covered itself in glory
on banking reform.
It's one of the weaker
areas of its reform agenda.
And so I think hopefully whoever
wins the next election, that
will be a big priority.
Because it seems like a very--
it's a potential quick
win to unleash investment
in the economy.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thanks for coming.
One thing I'd like to talk
about is patrimonialism.
I mean, Mukesh Ambani,
who you mentioned,
his father was a
big businessman.
And there are large sections
of the political class
who are there thanks to the
family connections or whatever.
And even in Bollywood,
it's the same.
So do you see that
as being something
typical of economies that are
in this stage of development,
or is that unique to--
what are your thoughts on that?
JAMES CRABTREE: Yeah, it's
interesting, isn't it?
You're right that in
politics, the lock hold
of dynastic politics in India
has actually in some ways
got stronger over the
last 10 or 20 years.
So you have the
Nehru-Gandhi dynasty,
which is famously the kind of
dynasty of the Congress Party.
One of the reasons why
Narendra Modi is so interesting
is he's not a dynasty.
He doesn't have any children.
And so he's not trying
to build a dynasty.
But for various sort of
sociological reasons,
many of which are
wound up in corruption,
having these dynastic
regimes in politics
has become more common.
And it's certainly a
feature of Indian capitalism
that the family-owned
conglomerate
remains the dominant form
of business ownership.
And predictions
of the decline of
the family-owned conglomerate
are often made by outsiders.
And they very
rarely come to pass.
In actual fact, it seems in many
ways as if that-- and its true
across Asia-- that
the conglomerate
as a form of business remains
as dominant as ever it was.
And so you mentioned
Mr. Mukesh Ambani.
His company has become
more conglomeratish
over the last five or 10 years.
It's got broader.
And he's moved into more areas.
I tend to think that
in the medium term--
again, some of these factors
will decline a little bit.
Part of the reasons
why conglomerates
and family-owned conglomerates
are so dominant in India
are because you need
to keep functions
within the business
that typically would
be done outside in other areas.
So you need to recycle
capital within the business.
You don't trust the legal
system to guarantee trade
with other companies.
So you keep them within
your own company.
As India moves towards a more
neutrally-administered sort
of pro-market, well-regulated
economy, some of that
will dissipate.
And again, if you can
fix parts of the funding
of the political system,
then some of the reasons
for keeping all of the money
in the financial system,
within the political system,
within different families,
will dissipate as well.
But I don't think India
is going to, in a sense,
end up where America
and Britain are.
The notion that the
form of modernity
that India is moving towards,
this sort of Francis Fukuyama
model that we're all
going to kind of end up
with a form of Western
politics and capitalism,
I think that's pretty
clearly not going to happen.
And so wherever India
ends up is going
to be its own form
of these things.
And so I suspect some
form of dynastic politics
and conglomerate-based
business is
going to be with us for
a long time to come.
ARUN VENKATARAMAN: Amazing.
The book is called
"The Billionaire Raj."
I'd highly, highly recommend it.
I think you do a phenomenal job
in just a series of portraits
of the billionaire Raj,
kind of this class,
really getting at a lot
of the thorny issues that
are central to India's
development over the course
of the next half century.
Thanks, James, for being here.
JAMES CRABTREE: Excellent.
Thanks a lot.
It's a great thrill to be here.
[APPLAUSE]